Mày mẹ mẹ tăng thăm ba Malaysia sắc nhận thật tòn thương mại đối ứng quyết Mỹ không còn hiệu lực.
Sau khi toàn tôi gặp Mỹ báo bảo chính sách thời quan của chính quyền tổng thống Mi đô nên trăm.
Bộ trình thương mại Malaysia cho Harry Atron gà đi khẳng định.
Thật tòn không bị đình chỉ mà đã chứng rất tổng tài, zôn nền tảng pháp li không còn.
Theo ông Jo Harry phán quyết của tòa Nếu cầu cơm mức thời phải có cơ sở cựu thề, không thể áp dụng chứ dọng như chưa đây.
Thật tòn ký hồi tháng người cuy định hàng xuất khổ của Malaysia sạm Mỹ trưởng mất hối mười chính phần chăm.
Fiam Malaysia cho rằng mối xin tân gần làm gió các cân cựa tối và phạm vi ngành hàng biện hưởng.
Chúc khi đó, Mỹ chưa đưa ra bình luận chính thức về tuyên mô này,
giờ có sát nhìn đẩn thái của Malaysia có thể làm ra tăng căn thằng thương mại sông phương.
Đà biệt trong mối cảnh chính sách thương mại của Mỹ đang có nhiều bình đậu.
Một số kính tệnh báo Nguy cơ pháp sình các biển pháp đáp trả,
nếu hai bình công duy trị đối thoại dụng qua,
sẽ biến mơ cho tới quanh thương mại Malaysia Mỹ đang phải đối mặt mối như thế thức.
Đời hỏi sự điều trình thận chẳng từ cả hai phía.